am 20 märz soll es wieder
friedensgespräche zu syrien geben
die große frage ist hilft es den
menschen mehr als die hälfte ist
vertrieben mehr als 500.000 tote sind zu
beklagen
das ist die große frage vor genf 5 am
zwanzigsten treten
[Musik]
wie stellt sich die situation in syrien
heute da präsident assad ist mit
massiver russische und iranische
unterstützung auf dem vormarsch der fall
von ostalb hat eine wende im krieg
gebracht er ist eindeutig in der
stärkeren position und geht davon aus
dass das land zurückerobern kann
wir haben aber nicht nur satt wir haben
auch die opposition und wir haben den
islamischen staat die
terrororganisationen sind zweifellos
massiv in bedrängnis geraten ist
allerdings noch immer wichtige
positionen im lande hält die opposition
befindet sich eine sehr schwierigen lage
welche den kampf militärisch sicher
nicht mehr gewinnen kann und sie muss
sich daher entscheiden ob sie am
verhandlungstisch etwas erreichen will
oder am boden weiter kämpfen will die
kämpfe untereinander sind immer heftiger
geworden mittlerweile und die große
frage ist wer davon ist bereit zu diesen
friedensgesprächen zu kommen und welches
mandat hat aber kann man denn überhaupt
verhandeln grundsätzlich welche wege
gibt es um aus einer kriegssituation wie
diese herauskommen zu können
eine möglichkeit ist der militärische
sieg von einer seite das versucht als
hat das ist aber sehr schwierig weil es
ja nicht nur zwei seiten gibt es mit den
terror organisation noch im wesentlichen
er dazu eine zweite möglichkeit ist dass
man hier von internationaler seite eine
ganz intensive militärische intervention
durchführt und quasi einen frieden
erzwingt das hatten den großen 19 95 ist
aber in syrien überhaupt nicht abzusehen
eine dritte möglichkeit ist dass sich
die konfliktparteien soweit einigen und
durch verhandlungen zu einer lösung
kommen mit massiver unterstützung von
außen das ist genau das was man in gehen
kann derzeit versucht und die vierte
möglichkeit wäre dass alle
konfliktparteien so erschöpft sind und
gar nicht mehr weiter kämpfen können
keine der situationen trifft wirklich
auf syrien zu wir haben von allem ein
bisschen etwas und ich habe mich auch
skeptisch was den erfolg dieser
gespräche sein kann hat glaubt wie man
auch militärisch gewinnen zu können
die opposition wird dazu gezwungen sich
zu entscheiden zu kämpfen oder zu
verhandeln
dass nicht alle goutieren der islamische
staat ist ein gedränges ist aber immer
noch da aber bei den gesprächen
überhaupt nicht eingebunden
daher jetzt hier relativ wenig
herauszuholen seines wird mühsame
politische gespräche geben
auf der positiven seite kann sein dass
sich hier die kräfte und die kämpfe
konzentrieren auf die bekämpfung der
terror organisation islamischer staat
und dass dadurch auch durch die
gespräche freiraum geschaffen wird und
wieder mehr humanitäre hilfe ins land
kommen kann vielleicht sogar einige
leute zurückkehren können in die häuser
wie wir es in den letzten wochen schon
gesehen haben
man kann nicht erwarten dass in games
der große durchbruch erzielt wird
allerdings jedes ergebnis jedes
verhandlungsergebnisses besser als
diesen blutigen kampf fortzusetzen